[Music]
let's go to ashley and manchester what's
up ashley how are you
good how are you dr john good things
going well
yeah uh my question for you today is how
do you have the
this is where babies come from with a
child that has been sexually abused
without it being a trigger for them ah
that's a good question so tell me more
okay so
um
our daughter she is eight
um she
was in foster care we adopted her out of
foster care um
about a year ago she's been with us for
about three years she was sexually
abused by her bio dad
um so we've come come a long way with
her
but obviously those questions are going
to start coming up
um
and i guess i'm trying to just
get ahead of what um
what that looks like and how to really
handle that i love it um a couple things
one
thank you for
loving the kids in your community taking
one home that's that puts you in rare
error and i'm grateful to have gotten to
talk to you today just you you've made
my day better just you and you you and
your family are incredible thank you
um how old was she when the abuse
happened
um so she was originally put into foster
care when she was five okay
like the
i know you feel this and this show's not
about me
the insta rage that happens when i hear
that is profound right
my daughter's six and so i
i gotta stop catch my breath a little
bit um so daughter got put in foster
care where's dad now
um he is in prison excellent
way to go america all right so
that's just an aside so uh the date is i
mean the age is important for a couple
of reasons but
um yeah
has she started asking questions yet as
she started getting into some of this
stuff like tell me where she is
so
um a little bit just because my sister
is about to have a baby so it brought up
um you know
i've brought up some questions and like
what's happening
so
has any of
any of your conversations about quote
unquote what's happening
um about your sister being pregnant has
that sent her into any sort of rage or
anger or crying or hiding or anything
like that
um
no okay
that's so here's
i guess with the conversations we have
had
um i've more
just tried to avoid it okay because i
don't know
if it's going to be a trigger for her or
um
i guess we really haven't had like a
deep
you know yes age-appropriate
conversation yeah yeah okay so here this
is uh so glad you're calling this is
incredible i'm so glad you're calling
all right
so
what we want to do with her
is begin to here's what healing looks
like for her
that she can understand that the one man
on planet earth that was supposed to
love and take care of her
um stole from her took from her right we
want her to be able to have that
understanding
and yeah also her body not take off on
her okay right
and that's the healing journey she's
gonna be on for a while right and that
will manifest itself in different ways
and i'm assuming she's in counseling and
getting the care and love that she needs
the
question was
okay
um so we were doing when she first came
to us
um we were going play therapy okay
um which was great
but then the counselor that she had
um
moved on and was getting a different job
okay and
um
they kind of the way they put it to me
was they were graduating her from
counseling okay hey that's actually a
good thing okay that means a group of
professionals looked at your child and
said
this kid's incredibly resilient she's
going home to a stable family and she at
this time has
able to
she's able to handle um these thoughts
and feelings when they come up right
she's got a plan right yeah
so
here's what we want to do with her and
with all kids quite honestly
is we want to teach them that their
bodies aren't weird or gross or somebody
else's gymnasium
and the way we do that
is by norming talk about body parts
about penises and vaginas and how they
work and where babies come from and
right all those things and so when if
you like
when your kid says how'd that baby get
in there and your eyes widen real big or
your pulse starts racing you're like i
don't want to say the wrong thing
your kid absorbs we don't talk about
that here
okay and or
how does that baby get out of there
and you instantly turn bright red and
you're like i don't know
yeah as opposed to
you have a vagina it's a special place
in your body that only
yeah the baby's right instead of it
being as though we're having a
conversation about a sidewalk or about
bushes in the front yard right
um right anything that deviates from
that kids are incredibly perceptive
about what mom will and will not talk
about dad will and when i talk about so
norm body talk okay don't be weird so
i'm saying like
don't worry about setting off a trigger
if a trigger shows up somewhere
um you'll know you'll know
right and then then that will be a
conversation a circle back with a
therapist that says hey every time we
happen to mention
um hey you need to wipe when you after
you get done go to the bathroom which is
the conversation you have that you're
old right
we go by the toilet they haven't flushed
and there's no toilet paper in there
right
every time we talk about wiping
she smashes the door or she doubles down
the floor and starts crying that's going
to be a circle back and that's going to
give the therapist some data until then
okay don't let them absorb one thing
about how their body is wrong or other
okay that's gonna feed into the original
violation which is your body is somehow
causes your body it's your body's fault
that there's pain that daddy's in jail
that you don't feel loved that you see
what i'm saying
um does that make sense this also shows
up with your other kids shows up with
your husband and you like just not being
weird about talking about body parts and
here's the magic here's the other magic
um when she's
11 12 or she's gonna ask questions about
menstruation and tampons and how does
that work and why do you have that mommy
just be happy just just tell her as a
matter of fact it is because it is a
matter of fact and we've become so weird
about our bodies right and
yeah um
there is a book that my friend um i've
talked about on the show dr jennings
gave me
um it's i got a picture of it here and
we'll link to it in the show notes i've
got no affiliation with this book i
don't make any money off this book
anything like that uh but it's by julie
federico f-e-d-e-r-i-c-o
and the book is it's i mean it's very
very thin and it's just called some
parts are not for sharing and it's about
teaching little kids
some parts of your body are for high
fives other parts covered by bathing
suits are for you
you yeah that makes sense
generally you say
mom dad and doctor and that's it
in this case she understands dad's not
safe
right right so for this season it might
just be mom right you see what i'm
saying
yeah
um but having just this little book that
says yeah some of these private parts
and then when you talk about cause she
might ask you a question about
is that aunt so-and-so's baby still
coming out of aunt so-and-so's vagina
she might ask you that at church or she
might ask you that in the store right
and you can say that's a private part
and we talk about that in private or we
talk about that we have that
conversation at home or we have that
conversation around the dinner table
right see i'm saying so there's a time
and a place but quite honestly we're
going to let those things happen
organically because an eight-year-old
isn't going to understand the
quote-unquote i i think the idea of the
quote-unquote talk
is is not good because
kids don't understand we're having a
moment right they understand
this thing got weird and dad got tense
and mom's acting strange and now we're
talking about this thing and i don't
know much but i will never bring it up
again right
versus
yeah because if it makes if you make it
weird then yes yes maybe that's
all of my babbling just now don't make
it weird
all right yeah and here's where this is
hard for parents
millions and millions and millions and
millions of us who are parents
didn't understand that our bodies
weren't gross or weird or somehow
to be hidden or shameful or something
until we were well into marriage and we
had to go see therapists to figure that
out right
you might be there and so you might have
to learn a whole new way of talking
about your body to yourself
and to your husband and your husband and
vice versa you see what i'm saying it
can be it can be weird because we've
never done it before
yeah that makes sense okay
i threw a lot at you tell me what you
think feel
no i think what you said you know makes
sense let it happen organically um and
yeah just be very
honest and
try not to make it weird and have you
talked to her about um
what her dad did have you all had that
conversation
yeah we have um which is
kind of hard because you know she
obviously
if
she has obviously she knows what he did
was wrong and she's mad at him but then
she's also
wants to you know go see him um and you
know still
it's like a yeah i don't know it's a
weird no it's it
and that is the
gap that will haunt her
for a long long time right until she's
able to her little brain is able to get
some distance and space between her
feelings and the actual reality of
things
because she's going to start and if not
she hasn't already she'll start in the
next couple years
beginning to blame herself for her dad
being gone
you know what i mean like i shouldn't
have said anything i shouldn't have told
it's my fault that dad i can't see dad
right and he might even play into that
hopefully he doesn't but he clearly
isn't a person a character up front so
um it will continue to
be part of y'all's conversation and she
will end up back in counseling just fyi
she'll come back
um puberty will be a whole new thing
right
but as we go there kind of what i was
wondering about you know because
as she gets older obviously things like
this are going to come up and you know
it brings up more questions and so the
challenge for her is going to be
delineating
she has to have touch moving forward
and
the person who's supposed to teach her
what safe touch is
violated that trust in a tragic right oh
ugly way so she's going to have to learn
that over the alarm system that her body
has sounded
right and that's just going to be the
magic of
therapy as she continues to navigate
this and you two you and your and your
husband the rest of the family
finding that balance between
no like touches and it's not an
important thing it's the important thing
it's it's grounding for our bodies you
have to have it and somebody use that to
hurt you it's like water right you can
drown in water and you can't go more
than a few days without it or we die
it's the same thing right
and so how if you almost drown i want
nothing to do with water and everyone
how do you reintroduce that that's the
magic that we're aiming for here i would
rather you over
i would rather you err on the side of
um
being completely open with her when she
comes to you
and
norming
talk about bodies in your house
then
adding another layer of
this happened to me and it's just not
okay to talk about because the person
who rescued me
she blushes every time somebody i ask a
question about pregnancy
see what i'm saying like in that
yeah i'd rather air on the other side i
also don't want you to take your
eight-year-old out for pancakes and be
like all right so we're gonna talk about
that's too young okay it's not too young
to answer questions it's too young for
the quote unquote big thing if uh when
she starts your period that's give me a
time when you all go out i want y'all to
celebrate that have a moment with that
right maybe get some other women in her
life that you can
say she's safe to call and she's safe to
call and she's safe to call
i think that'd be a cool thing right um
and here's what this means it's like a
it's a moment
but i don't know that
he's a little bit young to go all right
here you know what i mean to have that
talk i have had to talk with my middle
schooler
yeah
and i've talked about sex with my
six-year-old but when she brings it up
right okay that makes sense and very
age-appropriate
you know what i mean very
age-appropriate way and it's not weird
or it's not anything in our house so um
hope that helps man
she's so lucky to have you
she's so so lucky to have you that
you're loving her and carrying her
better in that way um
she's been hurt at the deepest possible
level
in one of the deepest ways possible
by
the person who could hurt her the most
and that that
pain that wound will linger for years
and years and years and years
and the only way she heals is through
relationship connection
learning what good touch is learning
what safety is and learning over time
how to regulate her body when it takes
off on her in situations
it's gonna be a tough road to hoe and
that's why
you and your family and your husband
y'all are incredible they are absolutely
incredible and i'm just grateful to know
you guys are out there
everybody
norm talk about bodies just norm it it's
all right